[Musique]
lorsque nous sommes allés le voir en
répétition en début de semaine nous
sommes tombés sur un homme pour centrer
je pas tabac tue renault
[Musique]
francky vincent supporte deux casquettes
celle d'artiste et celle de producteur
mais quand on interroge très vite le
personnage fuji provocateur reprend le
dessus chacun sait qu'un de karuïa c'est
énorme pour moi pour les gens qui
m'apprécient énormément et pour ceux qui
n'aiment pas trop ce que je fais ça les
fichiers sévèrement quoi faut appeler
cha cha
[Musique]
ça fait qu'on aime ou qu'on déteste
c'est l'un des artistes entier les plus
connus dans l'hexagone
son coup de génie donné dans le grivois
le baya un répertoire unique chanter en
français pour toucher un public
francophone
le déclic lui est venu en guadeloupe
j'allais souvent à la plage et
j'entendais des touristes à côté de moi
dire il ya un mec là on l'a vu à la télé
en train de chanter et il a dit quelques
mots en français j'ai compris ça parle
de q1 et là ça fait de si je me suis dit
pourquoi ne veut pas ne vais pas chanter
des chansons mais vraiment en chantant
tout ou en français pourquoi les
métropolitains puisse m'adapter
alors pour ce concert anniversaire pas
de véritables surprises au programme des
chansons essentiellement en dessous de
la ceinture
ces choristes qui travaille pour la
première fois avec lui ne s'en formalise
pas j'aime bien cette maison que cet
indic entraînante chose est d'habituer
donc voilà je pense que les gens ou al
adha sociaux wallons restent pas
insensibles
en fin de compte c'est la musique qui
passe à deux partout d'autant que samedi
soir à dammarie les lys en qui va s'en
sera accompagné de musiciens de renom
comme my clinton à la basse et wilfred b
d'acier à la batterie
de la passion
[Musique]